[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las historias de nuestro continente
cuba vive un momento histórico una
protesta en defensa de la libertad de
expresión llevó a que en un movimiento
sin precedentes el gobierno invitará a
los disidentes a dialogar una promesa
que quedó en el tintero pero ya la
simple invitación es un hito en eeuu aún
sin reconocer la derrota el presidente
de donald trump dejó ver su intención de
aspirar a un segundo mandato en 2024 les
contamos si puede hacerlo
y les presentamos a un grupo de cowboys
o viajeros que lucha por reivindicar su
lugar en la historia de la unión
americana
y vamos de inmediato a cuba para nuestra
historia principal una inusual protesta
de artistas frente a la sede del
ministerio de cultura de la isla recibió
atención del gobierno de miguel díaz
canel y fue invitada a una reunión a los
manifestantes pedían la liberación de
denis solís uno de los miembros del
llamado movimiento san isidro un grupo
defensor de las libertades sin embargo
poco después la televisión estatal
cubana denunció los supuestos vínculos
del joven con eeuu y la promesa de
diálogo quedó estancada nuestro equipo
en la habana nos cuenta más
encerrado por insultar a un policía
dennis solís un joven rapero se ha
convertido en el símbolo de la censura y
la represión política en cuba su arresto
ha despertado una ola de acciones de
protestas que empezó con esta casa en la
habana donde decenas de personas se
unieron y se declararon en huelga de
hambre músicos académicos y periodistas
que hacen parte del movimiento sanisidro
un grupo defensor de las libertades
ciudadanas creo que es un buen momento
de despertar las conciencias de los
cubanos
intenta salvar la nación familiar
pero sólo diez días después la policía
llegó a la casa y desmanteló la protesta
argumentando violaciones a los
protocolos de seguridad contra el kobe
19 pero el movimiento ya había ganado
atención
un día después alrededor de 300 personas
participaron en una rara protesta a
favor de la libertad de expresión en las
afueras del ministerio de cultura en un
movimiento sin precedentes
la multitud recibió una invitación para
hablar con las autoridades 30 personas
les acaban de hablar honestamente lo que
nos está pasando nos está maltratando
nos están golpeando nos están haciendo
daño ellos escucharon escucharon mucho
sucedió bocyl pero la promesa de
conversaciones vivió poco la televisión
estatal cubana reveló imágenes de uno de
los principales integrantes del
movimiento en una reunión con un
diplomático de estadounidense el
presidente miguel díaz canel tomó eso
para promover la retórica de la
intervención estadounidense
de guerra no convencional para tratar de
enfocar la traducción
intentó que podía
los trópicos
los activistas rechazan las acusaciones
mientras que varios países han pedido la
liberación de solís de acuerdo con human
rigth watch el año pasado más de 1.000
cubanos fueron detenidos arbitrariamente
en cuba
vamos a eeuu nos vemos en 2024 dijo el
presidente de donald trump aún sin
reconocer la derrota en las elecciones
del 3 de noviembre trump abre así la
posibilidad de lanzarse nuevamente a la
presidencia en cuatro años después de
que el departamento de justicia
informará que no encontró pruebas del
fraude que el mandatario denuncia sin
fundamento
los veré en cuatro años
aún sin reconocer la derrota donald
trump empieza a apuntar a una
candidatura a la presidencia en 2024 el
mandatario de eeuu dejó ver que no tiene
intención de desaparecer de la escena
política y buscará mantener movilizados
a los más de 74 millones de personas que
votaron por él en las elecciones del 3
de noviembre
hemos tenido cuatro años increíbles
estamos tratando de hacer otros cuatro
años de lo contrario los veré en cuatro
años
y no hay nada que se lo impida la
constitución estadounidense permite dos
mandatos e incluye la posibilidad de
hacerlos de manera no consecutiva solo
un hombre ha tenido éxito con esa opción
grover cleveland a finales del siglo 19
fue el único presidente que logró
regresar al poder para un segundo
mandato tras perder la reelección
consecutiva llegó a la casa blanca en
1884 fue derrotado en 1888 y reelegido
en 1892 libren tenía 56 años al comienzo
de su segundo mandato don action tendrá
en 2024 78 años sin embargo desde
entonces los presidentes salientes se
han mantenido tradicionalmente alejados
de la política y se dedican a proyectos
filantrópicos o académicos la decisión
que adopte durand marcará
previsiblemente las elecciones de 2024
sin importar si decide hacerlo como
candidato o de una manera más discreta y
cuando pensamos en un vaquero
estadounidense nos imaginamos el
sombrero el lazo y el caballo
existe la posibilidad de que lo
imaginemos blanco sin embargo después de
la guerra civil un tercio de los cowboys
eran afroamericanos muchos de ellos
habían sido esclavos esa realidad ha
sido ignorada e incluso ha permanecido
oculta de los libros de historia y la
cultura pop y ahora un grupo de vaqueros
modernos está tratando de reconquistar
su legado
[Música]
con las botas el lazo y el sombrero luce
como todo un vaquero pero como hombre
negro morís way no concuerda con el
estereotipo de cowboy estadounidense sin
embargo eso es exactamente lo que es en
un rancho en colorado al crecer en los
años 60 su carrera no era un hecho
mientras crecía todas las películas que
veía eran del salvaje oeste mis héroes
siempre eran los vaqueros pero solo veía
hombres blancos en los caballos rápidos
y luego me decidí a ser el hombre negro
que lo hiciera
de hecho como este poco conocido museo
de denver colorado explica casi un
tercio de los vaqueros eran negros
durante la conquista del oeste cuando
eeuu expandió sus fronteras hacia la
costa del océano pacífico la mayoría
eran esclavos liberados que eligieron la
difícil tarea de pastorear el ganado que
encarnaba la libertad pero quienes han
contado la historia han borrado esa
realidad guay que los niños veían
vaqueros blancos así que nunca pensaban
en un vaquero negro
james arthur walker inventó el brinco de
hollywood en el que estás en un caballo
saltas del lado y aterrizó en el suelo y
luego saltas de nuevo en la silla una
ovación o hardware ahora eso está en
todas las películas de vaqueros pero
nadie conoce a ese hombre
ese hombre allí es quien lo inventó como
anne joven pene
[Música]
y es que hollywood jugó un papel
importante en borrar la imagen del
vaquero negro desde los años 30 había
películas de vaqueros de color como se
llamaban en la época pero eran
producciones de bajo presupuesto que
sólo estaban dirigidas a los cines para
los afrodescendientes en los eeuu
segregacionistas en los años 50 y 60
durante la segregación y el movimiento
por los derechos civiles los ejecutivos
de las cadenas y directores de los
estudios de películas no tenían la
valentía de poner a un hombre negro en
un caballo y llamarlo un héroe en el
resto de eeuu estaban disputando esa
pelea probablemente la película de
vaqueros negros por excelencia sería boy
and the freezer con sidney poitier y
harry belafonte
hoy una generación más joven de
afroamericanos está redescubriendo la
herencia de los vaqueros negros
[Música]
a sus apenas 12 años sábana roberts ya
ha ganado varios títulos en campeonatos
de rodeo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y quiero asegurarme de ser un modelo a
seguir para los demás los afroamericanos
más jóvenes yo simplemente quiero que
sepan que nadie puede decirles que no
pueden hacer esto o lo otro su modelo a
seguir es echar sampson quien hizo
historia silenciosa en 1982 cuando se
convirtió en el primer afroamericano en
ganar el campeonato mundial de rodeo un
deporte emblemático en eeuu
una vez eeuu lidia con este problema y
entienda que estamos en la tierra de la
libertad y que somos iguales entonces la
raza no será una diferencia y estamos
trabajando en eso como estadounidenses
[Música]
desde lo político hasta lo científico
son los eeuu blancos son los que han
escrito la historia hoy los vaqueros
negros se quieren reconquistar el lejano
oeste
vamos a argentina tras la muerte del
astro del fútbol diego maradona el
equipo de france 24 en buenos aires ha
estado recorriendo los pasos del
futbolista en su ciudad natal visitamos
su casa en villa fiorito
la historia de amor de diego maradona
con argentina comenzó aquí en villa
fiorito uno de los suburbios más
modestos de buenos aires- en esta casa
nació el pibe de oro' su amigo de la
infancia
norberto recuerda a un niño que sólo
quería jugar al fútbol
interno con todos los chicos gana casi
jugar a la pelota viera su sueño
[Música]
llegar a ser profesional no esto que
debo hacer
él quería jugar profesionalmente como
cualquier jugador y poder ayudar a su
familia
un sueño que se hizo realidad de núcleo
cuyo estadio ahora lleva su nombre
argentinos juniors diez días antes de
cumplir 16 años
maradona inició su carrera profesional
consiguiendo un contrato y casa para él
y su familia
en la cancha de racing contra
racing-argentinos juniors racing baile
la fama de diego trasciende el fútbol se
grabó en los corazones de las personas
porque podían relacionarse con él con
motivos de orgullo y aspiración para
muchos aficionados devastados por su
muerte el gear pero el riego no se va a
morir nunca porque el que ama nunca
olvida acá en nápoles en todo el mundo
porque el donde estuvo dejó su su
granito de arena
quiero
maradona consolidó su nombre en la
cultura popular argentina pero su pase
al legendario club boca juniors en 1981
durante una ilustre temporada en la
bombonera
maradona bailó a los defensores rivales
ganando el campeonato nacional convoca
los fanáticos no lo olvidan
diego es único es único a nivel mundial
digamos por eso quisimos rendirle este
homenaje para que lo disfrute todo el
pueblo de boca es el astro máximo acá en
boca ese es el corazón del hincha de
boca nuestro país porque nos conocen por
diego maradona saltaría posteriormente
europa donde se convirtió en una leyenda
pero su corazón estaría para siempre en
argentina
el vínculo de diego con su país vivió
hasta su último aliento
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y me despido con estas imágenes que
llegan desde colombia arte rupestre que
la luz sobre los primeros habitantes de
la selva amazónica miles de dibujos
sobre rocas que datan desde hace más de
12.000 años fueron descubiertos en la
selva amazónica hace varios años pero
las comunidades locales ayudaron a los
exploradores recientemente a exponerlos
internacionalmente los dibujos dan una
vívida mirada a la vida de la época e
incluyen animales extintos como
mastodontes gracias por acompañarme en
esta emisión de aquí américa sigan en
france24
[Música]
en france 24